you're alive was there a question Midway
through that we were like I don't know
if I'm gonna survive this man just I
kept drilling drilling it down on me
obviously the conversation of the you
and Vanessa and Micah had about whether
or not
she could be a mom or the mom to your
kids came up I struggled with
um
at least in terms of envisioning Micah
as like you know a mother I think for me
it was like difficult for me to do it's
just sort of um
just like a nurturing aspect I think
that some people have
I don't know but whenever I tried I just
know that
I wasn't able to see it very clearly do
you feel like you've you've done as much
clarifying as you can possibly do on
that situation yeah I kind of do you
know I think I said my piece and I think
uh Vanessa might have had a little bit
of personal bias in that scenario or at
least I kind of detected that I don't
know but that's just my assumption based
on how she continued to drill into it
after I gave my full rationale for why I
felt the way that I did and I owned as
much as I could of that scenario and
took responsibility for
the full capacity in which I think that
I was obligated to
um then she continually said well why
didn't you do this why didn't you know
ask this of her why didn't you demand
this of her and I just like you know
that gets into the philosophical nature
of relationships and like is that right
to demand your person to change in order
to fit you like you know that's a that's
a debatable question on a scale of one
to ten how sweaty were you getting in
that moment I was sweaty yeah no doubt
no doubt I had drank and like or drank I
don't know like three cups of coffee
like immediately before during like the
lag the pause I was just chugging coffee
so yeah I was definitely sweating do you
feel like you you got the closure that
you needed from this live reunion do you
feel like there was still more that you
had to say or wanted to say or didn't
get the opportunity to say about your
journey on the show
yeah I do I I feel like there was a lot
of topics that involved me that I wasn't
given the opportunity to speak fully on
um and that's okay you know I think that
your character comes through no matter
what you say and your intentions come
through I think I don't know how but
it's very transparent I think on camera
like whenever you have good intentions
or you don't
um and so I don't necessarily feel
slighted but yeah I do have a lot more
to say on a lot of different topics what
was one of those top what was like
what's the bullet point of one that you
wanted to get across it was important to
you to get across that you didn't get
the chance to sure so I think that it
was extremely reductive in the way that
they dismissed all nuance and complexity
around why I said no so they said you
know it was framed as the reason why he
said no is that she wasn't
um able to fill a mother enroll in a
nurturing you know atmosphere or
whatever
um that was one piece of the puzzle this
is it was incredibly complex there was
so much more to that
um but that was the answer that was the
reason why and that's just a fraction of
the story man you know now when Zach
says that he felt like Michael was here
maybe not necessarily for the best
reasons to be you know maybe to find
Fame more than a relationship what was
your reaction is that something that you
guys had talked about in that long phone
call before the the wedding day
no that really didn't come up until
after you know we heard a lot of things
I think they were a bit disconcerting
um from third parties uh claiming that
you know she had told them those types
of things and so yeah it was rough to
hear and it definitely uh made me
question Things No Doubt
foreign